hello i'm martin olmander a developer
advocate on the serverless team
and i'm craig lebens a developer
relations engineer on the cloud sql team
oh cloud sql you say that's perfect
because i'm looking to deploy my app on
cloud run but its backend uses a
relational database
and i'm not sure how to combine the two
ah
yes many developers are using serverless
architectures with relational databases
why don't you show me what you're
building and we can take it from there
sounds good
[Music]
all right craig i've decided to settle
one of the greatest programming head
scratchers of
all time ah gif versus jiff
uh no not that one uh
what color is the dress no craig i said
programming i've created a web app to
poll whether developers prefer
tabs or spaces in their code oh i love
that idea because the answer will
obviously be
now your app is definitely going to get
millions of daily active users from day
one so you'll need to be thoughtful with
its infrastructure
can you show me what you have yep
my apps code is ready to go there's a
simple front end
that displays the most recent votes plus
the totals
also there's a form at the bottom that
collects new votes
okay that sounds like a pretty standard
web app now you mentioned using sql for
its back end
what went into that decision well
i plan to have several cloud run
services that periodically run
analysis on my data and sql is really
good at aggregations
like sums and averages yeah that makes
sense
it sounds like cloud sql is actually the
right choice for your app
oh that's good to hear but my fear using
sql with a serverless architecture is
that
postgres and mysql databases that they
don't scale up automatically like cloud
functions or cloud run
oh we've all been there now luckily
traditional sql databases have a lot of
tricks you can use to squeeze every last
drop of performance out of your hardware
what do you say we deploy your app and
then we'll run some load tests
sounds good let's get this baby shipped
all right
so i'm ready to create my database
instance here
in cloud sql i click create instance
and ah the first thing it asks me for
database engine do you have any
recommendation
well all three provide a modern sql
database but the community seems to be
agreeing on postgres style sql for new
products
so looking ahead choosing postgres will
set you up nicely for upgrades in the
future
but of course every decision that we
make here will be the same for mysql or
sql server
all right so i'll call my instance poll
database there we go
and i'll enter super secret password
here
let's see secret password
all right um now regarding location uh
i'm in california so i'm physically
closest
to let's see ah u.s west
um but to make sure i have the same
experience as users for
far from california i think i'll deploy
my app to
um maybe europe north oh that's so
clever
by not deploying your app to the nearest
region
you'll be able to see if users far from
your servers have degraded
experiences yeah
and of course if i know that all my
users are in one place i would deploy my
app to that region
but i have a question craig i put this
in finland now
but can i then relocate my cloud sql
instance later on oh yes of course
moving your database location is as easy
as creating a read replica in your new
region
waiting for it to catch up to your main
database and then promoting it
all right cool next one is database
version
i'll pick the latest available
configuration
options it says there uh oh there is a
lot here
yeah there is luckily uh they're not too
bad the first item connectivity offers a
lot of different ways of establishing a
secure connection to your database
the private ip option allows you connect
to a virtual private cloud
but i don't recommend that for newer
apps okay yeah i want to start simple
but in a way that doesn't prevent me
from growing in the future
for sure and you can always add a
virtual private cloud down the line
should you desire
so this means the default connectivity
option should be exactly what you want
because cloud run is designed to connect
to cloud sql
right out of the box i love it when
things work right out of the box
okay so closing connectivity i'm opening
machine
type and storage what should i pick here
now here i usually start with the
smallest machine that qualifies for
google service level agreement which is
one virtual cpu and 3.75 gigabytes of
ram
now estimating hardware needs ahead of
time is extremely difficult for any app
especially one not yet launched which is
why we're going to run some load tests
cool so i pick one virtual cpu 3.75
gigabytes of ram here but
what if i find out that i chose the
wrong size
later on what then well if your app can
tolerate a few minutes of downtime more
database power is never further away
than turning off your instance
resizing it and turning it back on of
course if your app cannot tolerate a few
minutes of downtime
then the standard workflow is the same
as changing regions you create a larger
read replica
wait until it catches up to production
and then promote it
now next as for storage type and
encryption i strongly recommend solid
state drives and google managed
encryption
those are easy wins and they reduce your
headaches
okay uh let's see so it looks like next
is backups ah great looks like backups
are on by default
and closing backups uh then we have
flags maintenance query insights and
labels uh that sounds like extra credit
so i think we might be good to go
i'm clicking create you've taken your
first step into a larger world
but say we've got a few minutes while
this database instance gets created
top off coffee uh well t for me but yeah
that sounds great
all right i've refilled my tea and my
database is created
before we go any further i'll use cloud
shell to create all of my tables
so if i scroll down here i can click
connect using cloud shell
all right so i'm in and i'm going to
paste in the
statements to create the tables there it
is
right so now my next uh question is what
values should i use in my
code to connect to my cloud sql instance
well usually you would use your
database's ip address but cloud run
creates a unix socket in your running
container
for each connected cloud sql instance
this means all that your application
code has to do is point to
that socket file i sent you a working
code sample earlier
did you get it uh socket txt yeah right
this is the one you sent to me right
yes so with that you can
copy that and go back into main.pi
and you can remove the host and port
arguments
and instead supply that copied code as
the path to your unix socket file
and like all of your other database
connection values it's best to read that
path
from an environment variable
now in cloud run the path is always
slash
cloud sql slash your database connection
name
which you can find on your cloud sql
instance screen
all right so i have
let's see i have an environmental
environment file here
i took out host and port
so and
in my database ah right there's the
connection name
cool i'll just copy that
so that's the connection yeah so you can
put all the values in this file
and for the database user we use the
default postgres user of
postgres postgres got it and i'm sure
you remember your best in class pastor
bias
uncrackable and
and we also use the default postgres
database very nice okay
post progress there we are
all right so i placed a database
username
and password database name and
connection name
now it looks like we're ready to deploy
your app
uh so i have a script prepared that
handles the entire
deployment process well that sounds
amazing
can i see it uh i'll just start it real
quick here
so what this does is uh up here it sets
three environment variables that will be
used further down and then it's two
steps so the first one is gcloud builds
submit which just packages everything up
in this directory and sends it to cloud
build
a google build server that builds the
container
that's what's going on right now and
then down here
is gcloud run deploy which takes that
container and deploys it as a new cloud
run
service also it includes here
add sql instances flag that sends along
the connection name so that cloudrun
knows
which database to connect to wow and to
think now you can deploy your entire app
with just a few key presses
this is really going to lend itself to a
nice ci cd pipeline
hey it looks like the deploy was a
success uh let's see if it loads
i'll go to this url here
it looks like i've connected cloud run
which is serverless with a traditional
sql database running on dedicated
hardware
i can scale it up by adding cpu memory
or read replicas
but will i need to do that how much
traffic can my system handle craig
well all apps are different the only way
to know is to run a load test
sounds great stay tuned for the next
video where we do that
you